Speaker 1: Hello, everyone. Welcome to The David
Pakman Show. I'm producer Pat Forde, filling in
for David today as he continues his paternity
leave. David should be making his triumphant
return to the show soon, relatively soon. But
he's, of course, taking this time to enjoy himself
as a new parent and to spend some time with the
little one and get some sleep whenever he can find
the time to. Today, we're gonna be talking about
a number of different topics. We're going to be
talking about the January 6th hearings. We're
going to talk about inflation and gas prices
and all these different things. But I wanted to
start today talking about gun control, because
there's a new bipartisan deal in the Senate on
the topic of gun control, and it actually includes
ten Republican senators, which is crucial because
that means there's a solid chance of this actually
passing in the coming weeks and becoming
law. I don't want to celebrate it too much
because for one, it hasn't actually happened yet.
Right. And these things could fall through. We we
need to see the actual text, but also it
seems a little bit lackluster. It doesn't come
nearly close to all the things that we have to
do to actually make a difference when it comes to
guns and gun safety in this country. But given
the fact that Republicans have been steadfast in
their refusal to do anything about guns in
the wake of mass shootings over the years,
it's hard to not feel some level of optimism over
this announced agreement. The deal will include
support for state crisis intervention orders,
funding for school safety resources, an enhanced
review process for buyers of guns under the age of
21, and penalties for straw purchases. That's when
you have one person purchase a weapon on someone
else's behalf. The legislation will also have a
red flag provision so that states and courts will
have the resources to make sure firearms are kept
out of the hands of people who are at significant
risk of doing harm with them. There's also going
to be increased funding for mental health, suicide
prevention and trauma intervention, which is,
of course, an important aspect to all of this. We
know that the right wing in this country loves to
claim that mass shootings are all about mental
health and that they're just exclusively a mental
health issue. We know that they just use it as
a red herring. But there's there's something to
that, right? Because that is one aspect in all of
this. And we have to not only look at gun control
measures, we have to look at the mental health
side as well. So if they're willing to have a
good faith conversation about mental health, we
should absolutely take them up on that and take
advantage of it. The ten Republican senators who
have signed on to this piece of legislation that's
in the works are John Cornyn, Thom Tillis, Richard
Burr, Roy Blunt, Bill Cassidy, Susan Collins,
Lindsey Graham, Rob Portman, Mitt Romney and Pat
Toomey. The centrist Democrats who tend to torpedo
pieces of legislation that we like as progressives
and Democrats. Those are Joe Manchin and Kirsten
Cinema. They've also pledged their support. So
this is very, very promising. Joe Biden said about
this, quote, Obviously, it does not do everything
that I think is needed, but it reflects important
steps in the right direction and would make the
most significant gun safety legislation to pass
Congress in decades. Alexandria Ocasio-Cortez
said about the bill. If we get a real baby step,
not kind of a distraction from the solution, she's
going to support it. So both Biden and AOC kind
of providing the same sentiment there that like,
yeah, this is great and all, but we could just do
so much more if we had more willingness from the
Republicans to do anything about guns. Sadly, I
think this is going to be treated as the solution.
That's probably what we'll see. We'll probably see
this get signed into law and then they'll do some
sort of victory lap and everyone will pretend as
if we actually did something significant when it
comes to gun safety in this country, when we know
we can just go so much further. You know, there
are some solid provisions in this legislation,
that's for sure. But we know that we can do more
when it comes to universal background checks,
raising the legal age to own a semiautomatic
rifle to 21 magazine capacity limits. None
of that stuff's in there. So maybe we can try
with future legislation, but it just doesn't
seem like it's going to be able to happen any time
soon. For as long as we have such a slim majority
in Congress and for as long as Republicans are
not willing to compromise on much when it comes
to this issue. So definitely go ahead, pass
the bill. Let's try to avoid the victory laps
afterwards. I want to see us try to make this a
voting issue come the 2022 midterms, because it
seems like now we do have somewhat of a chance of
maybe holding on to the House and Senate. It would
be great to to pick up an extra two Senate seats,
because that means that we could potentially
eliminate the filibuster and do so much more. And
I think, you know, this focus on abortion and gun
control at this point, given how the economy is,
might have to be the path forward for Democrats.
The kitchen table issues tend to be more economic
and financial issues. And there's some aspects of
that that, you know, we're having a tough time
communicating about because gas prices are so
high, inflation so high. So maybe given this
a. Courts leak draft opinion when it comes to
abortion. Maybe, you know, the mass shootings
and the backing for new gun control measures,
that's going to be enough to maybe propel
Democrats to hold on to the majorities. But we
just don't know yet and we really don't know what
the big issues are going to have to be once it's
actually time to vote. So that's the latest when
it comes to gun control. It looks like we're going
to have some piece of legislation pass through the
Senate and the House, and that's very good to see.
Last Friday, we got the new consumer price index
data and we found out that the inflation rate year
over year for the month of May was 8.6%. There was
this idea before the numbers were released that
maybe inflation had peaked over the past couple of
months and we'd start to head down a little bit.
But this new data release really throws a
wrench into that theory because we're still
trending upwards, albeit slightly. In March,
we were at 8.5% year over year inflation.
In April, we declined modestly to 8.3%.
And in May, once again, we went up to 8.6%.
It was predicted by economists ahead of the CPI
data release that inflation would go down to about
8.2%. So instead of being slightly down, we're
heading slightly up. The Consumer Price Index,
or CPI is a broad assessment of prices in the
economy, including everything from food to fuel to
housing to discretionary products. The main reason
for the CPI increase appears to be that gas prices
have gone up quite significantly over the past
month or so. Gas prices due to pent up demand in
the economy, given the recovery from the pandemic
and due to Russia's invasion of Ukraine and other
factors continue to go up, they just reached a
record $5 a gallon and it's likely a trend that's
going to continue all summer long because we know
that gas prices tend to go up with demand during
the summer months. And certainly the situation
in Russia and Ukraine has not settled down.
So we may see $6 a gallon gasoline relatively
soon. Who knows? So it's going to be difficult,
of course, to have CPI data going down when
you have gas prices going up so significantly.
If you're going to do that, you really have to
make up for it in the other categories that it
assesses. And we just did not do nearly enough
to make up for it. Interestingly enough, though,
core inflation, which removes food and energy
from the index is at 6% for the month of May year
over year, whereas in April is at 6.2%. So that's
positive. That's heading in the right direction.
But some people will say, well, you can't just
really take out energy and food costs from the
equation, given that they're such an important
metric of what takes place in the economy. The
CPI release caused the markets to tumble quite
a bit at the end of last week. On Thursday and
Friday we saw the major indices drop about three
4%. And the reason is that high inflation means
that the Federal Reserve is probably going
to have to be more hawkish when it comes to
raising interest rates, how often they're going
to raise the interest rates and by how much?
Because the idea is if you have high inflation,
you have to cool down the economy to encourage
less spending. And that means that companies
won't be able to make as much profit, which
means that investors won't make as much money,
which means that people often will sell off.
Aside from raising the interest rates, which is
really under the purview of the Federal Reserve,
there's not much that the Biden administration
can do when it comes to inflation and gas prices.
That's just the sad reality in all of this. When
it comes to gas prices. We know that he can take
more out from the Strategic Petroleum Reserve, but
that maybe will save you $0.10 here, $0.20 here.
It's not going to be enough to significantly drive
costs down. And we also know that the Strategic
Petroleum Reserve really is meant for emergencies.
So if there was a serious emergency that came our
way and we had just released a bunch of oil and
gas, that may not be the best thing to do. Just
about every country we know is dealing with the
high gas prices and the high inflation. So for
me personally, I have a tough time blaming Joe
Biden for this. The people who think that Trump
and Republicans would do better. I'd like
to hear how they would go about doing that.
I think there's just a sentiment of, well, with
Donald Trump and the Republicans were in charge.
We didn't have high inflation, we didn't have gas
prices. So clearly, if we put them back in charge,
they'd be able to get a handle on it. But that's
really just not how it works. Unfortunately, the
average voter doesn't know about that. They don't
know that presidents have very little control over
inflation and gas prices. So it's going to
be tough to communicate that to the American
people ahead of the midterms, especially when
these really are kitchen table issues. Can we
afford gas? Can we afford these other things?
Because prices everywhere are going up. So
it's a big challenge for Democrats heading into
the midterms. We definitely want to focus on gun
control and abortion because we're thinking more
and more. Those could be winning issues for us in
November. We also have to effectively address how
we're going to try to get a handle on inflation
and gas prices, even if it's just doing whatever
we can. Right, to make some sort of effort to
appeal to people to vote for us again. So that's.
The latest. When it comes to inflation, gas prices
doesn't seem like we have it under control yet.
Donald Trump has turned on his own daughter. And
no, I'm not talking about Tiffany, who Trump
doesn't seem to have the best relationship
with. I'm talking about Ivanka, who Trump
once said that if she wasn't my daughter,
perhaps I would be dating her. The context of this
betrayal goes back to the January 6th hearings,
which began on Thursday. We're going to
have day two of those hearings tonight
and they'll continue throughout the week. But
last Thursday, on the first day, there was
video testimony from Ivanka that was played and it
showed her basically saying that she did not agree
with the bogus election fraud conspiracy theories
as they were being made by Trump and his allies.
And she instead trusted the word of Attorney
General Bill Barr in his assessment that
what Trump and folks who were supporting him were
coming up with when it came to the voter fraud
stuff was just a bunch of hogwash. Now, we've
known ever since the beginning of the big lie that
Ivanka and her husband, Jared Kushner, were not on
board with the big lie. They didn't want anything
to do with it. They wanted Trump to concede
to Biden when it was clear that he had lost.
And, you know, Ivanka and Jared, they're not
really the most ethical people, but at the
very least, they were not willing to go along with
parroting the lies of Trump and the people around
him at the time who were trying to end democracy
effectively and the United States. But now we're
going a step further, because it's not just that
Ivanka Trump is trying to hide from the spotlight
when it comes to this voter fraud issue and the
2020 election stuff in general. She's actually
had to make a stand when it comes to this. And
she has with this video testimony saying that,
yes, she thought that what Trump and his allies
were saying at the time was bogus. Let's first
play the clip of what Ivanka said at that
testimony and then we'll go to Trump's reaction.
Speaker 2: I told the president in no uncertain
terms that I did not see evidence of fraud and,
you know, that would have affected
the outcome of the election.
And frankly, a year and a half later, I haven't
seen anything to change my mind on that. How did
that affect your perspective about the election
when Attorney General Barr made that statement?
Speaker 3: It affected my perspective.
I respect Attorney General Barr.
So I. Accepted what he was saying.
Speaker 1: Okay. So nothing over the
top there. Just a simple. Yeah, I agreed with
Bill Barr's assessment about the election and
didn't buy into the bogus voter fraud claims.
But Donald Trump will not allow even a modicum
of criticism to come his way from family members
or from anyone else. And so he just couldn't help
himself but to take the truth, social or truth
central, as he likes to call it, and he had to
post one of his truths, as they're called, quite
Orwellian least. So by the way, he posted, quote,
Ivanka Trump was not involved in looking at or
studying election results. She had long since
checked out and was, in my opinion, only trying
to be respectful to Bill Barr and his position as
attorney general. He sucked. So Trump is implying
two things there. One, that she didn't really mean
what she was saying. She was just trying to be
a kind hearted person and was trying to stay on
Bill Barr's good side. But also, it's evident from
this that her opinion really isn't all that valid,
right, according to Trump, because he says that
she's not well informed when it comes to the 2020
election. She checked out she wasn't one of the
primary people studying the issue. And that's
interesting because Trump and his allies have been
going around for the past year, plus talking about
how the fraud was so obvious that we can all
see it right. You don't have to study it too
extensively. You can just know by looking
at, you know, the voting machines and the
dead people voting and the ballot harvesting and
all of this nonsense stuff that clearly there was
election fraud in the 2020 race. Well, if it's
so clear that the general public can see it,
how come Ivanka Trump, who had a role in the White
House and presumably wanted to keep that role for
the next four years during a second Trump term?
How come she couldn't see it? Well, you know,
she just wasn't looking into it strongly enough, I
guess. So obviously Ivanka is on the right end of
this, but it's just fun to watch because we know
that Thanksgiving dinner this year is going to be
awkward at the Trump family residence. And, you
know, I think anyone else in Trump's position
after getting contradicted by your family member
would just do your best to ignore it. Right,
to keep shut. But Trump just can't help himself.
He had to take to social media to complain about
this. And, you know, I think this is probably
enough. It's just, you know, barely enough. But
I think it is enough to add Ivana Trump to the
list of people who Donald Trump has turned on
over the years who knew his own daughter. She has
made the naughty list. I talked about this next
story on last Friday's bonus show, but it's just
such an important media story. I thought it'd be
good to cover again today for the general David
Pakman show audience, and that is that as I was
watching day one of the January 6th hearings last
Thursday, I couldn't help but wonder, is Fox News
broadcasting this? Because on the one hand, it's
a highly relevant thing that's going on in the
world of politics. So you'd think that a news and
politics TV station would have to cover it. On the
other hand, the January six hearings are really
making Trump look bad, really making his allies
look bad, and even making Fox News personalities
look bad. Because, you know, we found out about
how Sean HANNITY was texting Kayleigh MCENANY
as the Capitol riots were unfolding, trying to
get her to get the president to get his supporters
out of the Capitol on that day. Well, what I saw
was Tucker Carlson show, and they had a live feed
up of the hearing, but they weren't playing audio
from it. They were just showing the visuals. And
Tucker went on the show and he brought on guests
and he was complaining about how the whole ordeal
was overblown and how we're not talking about the
real issues because we're so wrapped up at January
6th. Still, Carlson called the hearing deranged.
He called it insulting, and he took a moral stand.
He said that he was going to simply refuse to play
along the lower third graphics during the show.
That's the sirens at the bottom. They were saying
things like January 6th committee fuels false
narratives as sham investigation draws on. There
was another one that said leaders will spend 90
minutes giving moral lecture. A third one said,
Our leaders are focusing on January 6th
while ignoring the real threats. Here's a
clip from Tucker Carlson's opening monologue.
Speaker 2: Good evening and welcome to Tucker
Carlson. You know, it tells you a lot about the
priorities of our ruling class that the rest of
us are getting yet. Another lecture about January
six tonight from our moral inferiors, no less,
an outbreak of mob violence, a forgettable
minor outbreak by recent standards that
took place more than a year and a half ago,
but they've never stopped talking about it.
In the meantime, in the 18 months since January
six, gas prices have doubled. Drug loads have
reached their highest point ever. The U.S. economy
is now careening toward a devastating recession
at best. And scariest and least noted of all,
this country has never in its history been
closer to a nuclear war. Yet the other networks
cannot be bothered to cover any of that tonight.
Instead, they've interrupted the regularly
scheduled programing to bring you yet another
extended primetime harangue from Nancy Pelosi
and Liz Cheney about Donald Trump and Q and on.
The whole thing is insulting. In fact,
it's deranged and we're not playing along.
This is the only hour on an American news channel
that will not be carrying their propaganda live.
They are lying and we are not going to help
them do it. What we will do instead is to try
to tell you the truth. We've attempted
to do that since the day this happened.
We hated seeing vandalism at the US Capitol a
year and a half ago and we said so at the time,
but we did not think it was an insurrection
because it was not an insurrection. It
was not even close to an insurrection.
Speaker 1: Now, it's also interesting in
all of this is that during the entire broadcast,
they didn't actually cut to a commercial break.
And you have to wonder why that is, right? Because
it's a TV show. Like any other show. You're going
to go to commercials every 15 minutes to
give time for the sponsors. Well, what
appears to have happened is that Fox executives
didn't want people to have the opportunity to
change the channel. Right. Because if they go
to break at Fox, maybe people will tune over
to CNN or another news station, and then maybe
they'll come across the hearings with the audio
and then they may actually learn a thing or
two about January 6th. So couldn't have that,
which meant that you couldn't have commercials.
And that's really telling, right? Because
on the one hand, Fox is saying that January 6th
there was nothing. BERGER There's too much focus
on it. It was just a tourist visit, nothing
to see here. And on the other hand, they're
unwilling to go to commercial breaks. They're
unwilling to broadcast the hearing with audio.
So they definitely have something to hide when it
comes to all of this. And they want to make sure
that their viewers don't learn too much more about
the events of January 6th and the lead up. Now,
I'm sure we'll be talking more about the hearings
as they continue this week. But to be honest,
from day one of the hearings, I had mixed feelings
because I thought that the video testimonies,
those were effective. I thought that the footage
of the riots and, you know, the Trump supporters
who are fighting with the cops and all that
stuff, I thought it was very effective. What
I didn't think was so effective was some of the
long winded speeches and the testimony from the
police officer and the documentarian and the focus
on the proud boys and all that stuff. I think if
it was a little bit more condensed, it would be
more effective, but that's just my view anyway.
You're trying to appeal to people who haven't made
up their minds when it comes to January 6th, and
I think less is more when it comes to this stuff.
So we'll we'll see what happens over the next few
days as the hearings continue. If they are able
to engage with the audience any better and if the
public is able to come away from this all thinking
that there really needs to be consequences for
the people who were involved on January 6th,
because it was a terrible thing that happens
in our country and it should never happen again.
This next story is just an incredible display of
hypocrisy from Donald Trump and the so-called pro
free speech right wing truth social. The Twitter
copy that Trump made after he got kicked off
Twitter about a year and a half ago is reportedly
banning users for being critical of what happens
to the U.S. Capitol Building on January 6th,
2021. There are a number of reports of users
claiming that their accounts were suspended for
talking about what exactly happened on the sixth
and talking about the hearings and talking about
things that just simply make Donald Trump look
bad. Let's take a look at some of the screenshots
of people going to Twitter to complain about how
they were censored on truth social. A username.
Jack said I was suspended from Truth Social for
posting about the January 6th hearing last night.
Donald Trump is scared of free speech. Joseph
wrote Just put out my first post on Truth Social
and they deleted it. Real freedom of speech champs
there. And then a user named Travis said, quote,
My truth social account was just permanently
suspended for talking about the January 6th
committee hearings, including a screenshot of
his account being suspended. And I feel like you
already know what the analysis is going to be
here. This is just the most hypocritical thing
possible because like the whole point of truth,
social was supposed to be that it was going to
allow for free speech and the free exchange of
ideas, and they were not going to censor people
and ban people needlessly and all these different
things. But then you take a look at how it's been
in practice, and it's basically just been like
the right wing Trumpian version of Twitter,
which is fine if they want to do that. But it
was marketed originally as a free speech version
of the popular social media site, so they're not
really doing the things that they set out to do.
And the second that they see something that
they don't like, that they disagree with,
it's not talking about the
insurrection, things, talking about
Trump looking bad. They decided to take down
the post, they suspend the accounts. And there's
actually an argument to be made that they're
actually being more censorious than Twitter
is with some of these moves that they've made.
So what exactly is the point of truth, social?
I don't know at this point. They're changing it
day to day, it seems. Maybe it's just really to
make a site where Trump is able to speak his
mind and he needed to do something that involved
other users because the blog posts that he
had, the official messages from the office of
the former president, that just wasn't cutting
it anymore. And the bottom line is, they don't
care about the. Hypocrisy, right. Republicans in
recent years, they just don't even respond to the
points about hypocrisy burning when we
point out that they're doing one thing and
saying another. And what also isn't new is
the fact that truth social has these policies,
because even before they launched, it was clear
that they were going to censor certain posts
when it comes to disinformation, when it comes
to sensitive content. And then they also said
something at the very beginning, which was that
they were going to prohibit posts that disparage,
tarnish or otherwise harm, in our opinion, us and
or the site. So on truth, socially, you can get
censored or banned for daring to criticize Donald
Trump or Devin Nunes or the website at large.
And again, this goes to the point about this is
actually more censorious than Twitter is, because
it's not like Twitter has an analogous policy to
this. You can go on Twitter and criticize Twitter.
You can go on Twitter and criticize the executives
there. Clearly, there's a line you can't cross
with the criticism. Right? You can't be like
threatening anyone, but you're able to do generic
criticism just fine on Twitter. And while we're on
the topic of Republican hypocrisy on this issue,
I wonder if now that Republicans want Twitter and
these other social media platforms to be regulated
like public utilities, if they would say the same
thing about truth, social, if they want truth
social to be nationalized or socialized. I'm not
holding my breath. I would imagine that they want
it for Twitter but not for truth social. So that's
just the latest on truth social. I do think that
we're going to be talking more and more about it
as the months go on, because it appeared at first
that this was going to die out because they had
a really bad launch from a tech perspective and
things weren't working right. And also, there
was the news about Elon Musk planning to buy
Twitter. So there was this idea that he was going
to allow Trump back on Twitter. And at that point,
why even have a social media site of your own?
Why not just go back to Twitter? But for now,
Truth Social is here to stay and we'll have
to continue covering the blatant hypocrisy.
Republican Florida Representative Matt Gaetz is
probably not the wackiest member of Congress or
the dumbest member of Congress. I think we
have to give those titles to people like
Marjorie Taylor GREENE and Lauren Boebert and
Louie Gohmert. But Gates, he has to be the most
despicable member of Congress. Right. And there's
definitely some supporting evidence for this,
like starting with the fact that he's under
investigation for alleged sex trafficking and
prostitution of minors. You really don't have
to go further than that. Although, to be fair,
he's only been accused at this point.
But the investigation is well underway
and certainly the evidence against him continues
to mount. But as if we needed another example.
Here is Matt Gaetz chatting it up with
Marjorie Taylor GREENE on Greene's podcast,
and he makes the case that Jamie Raskin,
who is serving on the January 6th committee,
shouldn't be allowed to serve on the committee
because his son died by suicide not that long ago,
and the trauma from that must be clouding
his judgment. That's how Matt Gaetz put it.
Let's take a look at the video clip.
Speaker 4: What I worry about with Raskin in
all seriousness, you know, when people encounter
trauma, they often associate a lot of the other
things around that trauma with it, even if they
don't naturally or even rationally associate.
Speaker 3: Maybe so.
Speaker 4: And what I what I worry
about for the Congress and for for Jamie Raskin,
you know, no one would ever want to lose a child,
particularly to suicide. Of course, as a human
being, we actually our hearts go out to him. But I
think that he takes that trauma and he associates
it now with his work in the Congress to such an
interwoven way that he's unable to kind of do the
congressional experience outside of the just the
dungeon of that personal trauma. And I think it
makes him look at everything and these very like
dark and severe ways where, you know, we try to
come to the job really to uplift people, to we're.
Speaker 3: Here to serve the.
Speaker 4: People and we love
this country. Absolutely. We're out of a sense
of of grievance or hatred of America. We love
it. And we want to vindicate the rights of our
citizens. And we want to champion their causes,
travel, their dislikes. But I think for Jamie
Raskin, it's really like his service in the
Congress has almost become like inextricably
attached to the sad personal trauma he's had.
And I think it does cloud his judgment. And we
could see that that very darkness and that pain
manifest on on Thursday. Now, there's.
Speaker 1: Definitely multiple layers to
this story, but I think the main one is that Matt
Gaetz really just has to shut his mouth and not
invoke the name of Raskin's deceased
son to make a cheap political point.
Like we know what he's trying to do with this.
He makes this disclaimer about how we're not,
you know, wishing death on anyone or trauma on
anyone, Democrat or Republican. But come on. Like
we know the point that you're trying to make here.
The other layer to all of this is that logically,
it doesn't really seem to add up either, because
plenty of people experienced trauma at some point
during their lifetimes. Does that mean that
they have to quit their jobs or, you know,
not participate in certain aspects of their jobs?
Of course not. That doesn't make any sense. And if
so, like how much trauma is so much where you're
not able to perform your job responsibilities? The
whole thing just doesn't really seem to add up.
I don't know why he decided to make this point to
begin with, but this also goes to show that Matt
Gaetz is probably worried about the hearings and
the things that Raskin and the other committee
members are going to uncover, because we know
that Raskin certainly is a force to be reckoned
with and Matt Gaetz probably can tell that the
things that the committee is going to uncover in
the next few weeks is not going to be good for the
Trumpian right wing. AOC also responded to this
statement for Matt Gaetz with a tweet. She said,
quote, Rep Raskin is a greater statesman,
congressman, human being than most of us.
History will remember him. Tommy was a remarkable
person and testament of his parents love. Gates
is a bad haircut and a cheap suit, a feat of
mediocrity, given that he's here on Poppy's money.
Bye. So an excellent point there from AOC. You
got to wonder if Gates regrets this comment that
he made, because he really just doesn't look
good. He looks dumb, and he also looks like
he's insensitive when it comes to this stuff. So
you got to wonder, does he regret it? I also kind
of get the sense that he's the kind of person who
would just double down and really not care that he
did wrong and not admit to doing wrong with this.
Also during this appearance, Matt Gaetz brought up
the idea of giving Nancy Pelosi a sponge bath in
what was an incredibly weird moment. Luke Beasley,
who hosted on Friday, he talked about this,
but I just had to use this opportunity to play
that clip again. Let's roll it one more time.
Speaker 4: See your least favorite member. I
have a lot of mine. I'm on record.
Speaker 3: He at the top for me.
Speaker 4: Like I would rather give Nancy Pelosi
a sponge bath than endure like one dinner. That's
disgusting. Totally. But but just to just to bring
this up, I don't I'm going to call out for you,
okay? Like like a lot of people would say
maybe Pelosi is their least favorite member.
Speaker 3: Mr. Marciano, why did you turn, Martin?
Speaker 4: I would trim her toenails with my teeth
before I would go to dinner for the grandkids.
Speaker 3: That's really impressive. Chef. I
should say so. Here's how I feel about Out of Big.
Speaker 1: Yikes there. That was an uncomfortable
conversation and probably another example
of something that would have been better
left unsaid during this Marjorie Taylor GREENE
podcast appearance. And I'm wondering if Matt
Gates is going to be able to win his primary
in August or if he can win the general election
come November? Because certainly the first
District of Florida is very, very conservative.
But there are some real accusations against him
when it comes to this child prostitution and sex
trafficking stuff that I think even many members
of the right wing are not going to tolerate.
Like if they're given the option in Florida, in
this first district of voting for Matt Gaetz, who
is a Trumpian Republican and a cartoon character,
but also has these allegations against them
versus just another Trumpian Republican cartoon
character. They probably go with the second one,
right, because there's a lot less baggage when
it comes to that hypothetical other option that
they have. So I'm hoping that this is the last
seven months that Matt Gaetz is a congressman
and I hope it comes to an end for him either
because he's facing some serious criminal charges
or because he loses his reelection bid. We should
be finding out relatively soon whether Donald
Trump is going to be indicted for his role in
allegedly trying to overturn the presidential
election results in Georgia back in 2020. And
the person who is saying that the decision is
coming soon is someone who would know a thing or
two about it. It's Fulton County District Attorney
Fani Willis, who is the Georgia prosecutor,
investigating whether Trump broke election
laws in the state by trying to strong arm Brad
Raffensperger and get him to find the, quote,
11,780 votes. She told the Associated Press that
she expects to come to a decision about whether to
indict Trump by June 30th. Now, that sounds very
direct and it definitely sounds like it's coming
soon, especially because we're in the middle of
June now. But then we find out there's a catch
in that. That catch is that she actually made
the statement back in January. She said, quote,
I certainly think that in the first half of the
year, that decision will be made. But who knows if
between now and then things have changed, if the
timeline has been moved back. What is promising,
though, is that Willis has been ramping up her
investigation in recent months. She's interviewed
a few dozen people, including Secretary of State
Brad Raffensperger. She was granted approval for
a special grand jury, but has held off on
having witnesses testify before the jury.
Willis has also commented that she would want to
make the announcement after the primary elections
as to not give the appearance of a conflict of
interest or trying to influence the race in any
way. And those primary elections took place a few
weeks ago in Georgia. So now around now seems like
the right time to come out with the announcement.
Right. Are you going to indict him or are you not?
Especially because if she's worried about this
idea of election interference, then, you know,
you don't want to wait so long as to run up
against the November midterms. You don't want
to wait until right before the general election
either. So I'd imagine it's probably coming soon
to me. For what it's worth, I think that
Trump clearly broke the law on this. I
think it's a slam dunk case. If you look at the
Georgia election law, it says, quote, A person
commits the offense of criminal solicitation to
commit election fraud in the first degree when
with intent, then another person engaged in
conduct constituting a felony. Under this article,
he or she solicits requests, commands, importance
or otherwise, attempts to cause the other person
to engage in such conduct. And the punishment is
somewhere between one and three years in prison.
For what it's worth, and I'm no lawyer, but if
you take a look at the letter of the law there,
it certainly looks like Donald Trump
committed this crime and you at least
have enough evidence to go to an indictment and
we'll let the jury decide whether he is guilty.
They also have audio recordings of him. They can
establish that there was a well-planned, well
coordinated effort to do this. It certainly wasn't
a one off thing by Trump to like. He definitely
has a pattern of this. And there's witnesses
like you. You definitely have a solid case here.
So my sense is that if they decide not to indict,
it's going to be more of a political calculation
than a criminal one. They may just say, you know,
we've never prosecuted a former president. We
don't want to go down that road. So we're
going to let him off the hook here. And I
hope that doesn't happen. I hope that he's held
accountable. Also, someone who thinks that Trump
is going to be indicted in this Georgia case is
Eric Holder, who was Obama's attorney general.
Let's take a look at him saying that he
suspects an indictment is going to come soon.
Speaker 2: I think, you know, you can look at
what Merrick Garland is going to do. I think my
primary, my first analysis would be what's going
to happen to him in Georgia? Well, you've got
him on tape saying, you know, find me 11,780.
That one is close to a layup. It seems to me.
I've always said the same thing about that. Why
don't they just go after that one moment. It's
on. Tape. You have the smoking gun. He's saying. I
mean, I remember when Rod Blagojevich was on tape.
Basically, it didn't work out too well for him.
No, I know. But but it was it was it was it was
pretty blatant, but it wasn't as bad as find me
11,000 votes. Yeah. Yeah. No, I think as I said,
I think that's close to a lay up. The D.A.
down there is going to be calling witnesses,
I understand, before a special grand jury.
But the interesting thing there is that that
can also be a specification and a federal
charge that could be brought in Washington,
D.C. When you're charging him with conspiracy to
defraud and conspiracy to obstruct, what happened
in Georgia can actually be part of a federal case
as well. So I think, you know, I was a federal
prosecutor doing political corruption cases when I
first came to the Justice Department for 12 years.
And you get a feel for these things after a while.
I get the feeling that I can see where this one is
going and a lot of high level people in the Trump
administration. I suspect the president himself,
people at the Justice Department, are all going
to find themselves on a little document that says
the United States versus fill in the blank.
Speaker 1: So there you have it. Eric Holder
suspecting that Donald Trump is going to be
indicted in this Georgia election fraud case.
And I just get the sense that if Trump is going
to have to face any consequences for his alleged
wrongdoings, it's going to be because of this
Georgia case like the other investigations. I
just don't see them going anywhere at
this point. The one out of New York,
for example, there just doesn't seem to be
the appetite to charge him. And we've had
resignations because it seems clear that they're
just not willing to go in that direction.
Merrick Garland and the Biden Justice Department,
I just don't know if they want to open up a
can of worms and start this tradition of
presidents prosecuting former presidents.
Trump probably could get charged for his alleged
financial crimes and his role in the insurrection
and the hush money payments that he had Michael
Cohen allegedly issue and that Cohen went to
jail for. But to me, this one just seems like
it has the highest chance of actually getting
an indictment, going to trial and getting a
conviction. So we'll see how it goes. We're going
to find out whether Trump will actually ever have
to face consequences for anything in his life.
Kyle Rittenhouse is doing his rounds
in conservative circles. And the latest
on him is that there's actually a dispute
between him and Texas A&M University over
whether he's going to be going to school
there in the fall and taking classes.
Kyle said recently on the Charlie Kirk show
that he was going to be going to the university.
The university, however, says otherwise. They
say that he has not been admitted and won't be
taking classes there. How on earth did
this happen? Let's first go to the clip of
Kyle explaining to Charlie Kirk that
he is going to become an Aggie and
putting on the Texas A&M cap to celebrate.
Speaker 5: He's ready to make. This is like
he's ready to make it. Wow, everybody. It's a
big deal right here on the Charlie Kirk Show,
Kyle Rittenhouse is announcing that he's an Aggie.
Speaker 6: So I'm going to be going there and it's
going to be awesome. Beautiful campus,
amazing people, amazing food. We went
to Dixie to check in there. Best burgers.
Speaker 5: I've ever. That's why he's going.
Speaker 6: Texas chicken.
Speaker 5: Everybody. Now, do you know what they
say at A&M? They say gig him, gig them. And you
know how they say hello. They say howdy. Howdy. So
there you go. And so you're going to you're going
to be are you going to join the corps cadets?
Speaker 6: I haven't decided yet. I may.
Speaker 1: Well, that was all very interesting.
But the university disputes Kyle's claim on this.
Kelly Brown, who's the spokesperson for Texas A&M,
said, quote, He has not been admitted as a student
this summer or fall. Now, typically, when you have
one person claiming one thing and another person
claiming another, you have to sort of weigh the
arguments to determine who's in the right and
who's in the wrong or maybe who's telling the
truth and who's not telling the truth. With the
case like this, though, it's pretty clear that
whatever Texas A&M says goes like they're going to
be the correct ones in all this because it's up to
them. Right, that they don't want to allow him as
a student at the school, then he's not going to be
going to that school. And that's just kind of the
end of that. Like I could say that I'm going to
Harvard or Yale or wherever to take classes, but
if those schools don't actually admit me, then I'm
not going to be going to those universities. But
with regard to this Texas A&M situation, I just
wonder exactly how it happened. Right. Like. Was
he sent a denial letter, but he thought it was
an acceptance letter. Was he initially accepted?
And then they decided to rescind the acceptance.
Was there just some incredible misunderstanding?
What exactly happened? I mean, maybe there was
a planned charade with all this where he wanted
to force the university's hand into allowing him
to go to the school. And maybe he wanted to make
some broader point to a right wing audience about
liberal indoctrination and cancel culture at
college campuses. I'm just not exactly sure.
Funny enough, Kyle has been working on a grift
he calls the Media Accountability Project or Team
Map. I don't know why they didn't just go with MAP
for the acronym. They went with Team App, but team
app has the purpose of suing people for defamation
and going after the corporate press because Kyle
felt like he was defamed during his murder
trial. And so he wants to get revenge against
a bunch of people. But it's like one of those
things where, Kyle, if you're going to be doing
this, you're going to be working for team app.
You can't be going on Charlie Kirk's show and
saying things that aren't true because maybe the
organization is going to have to go after you.
Before this, Kyle was taking classes at ASU,
Arizona State University, and he dropped the
classes to focus on the homicide trial. He wanted
to resume classes there after the trial ended,
but a bunch of students had an uproar and
the university decided to cut ties with them.
You said in a follow up tweet that actually he's
going to be going to Blinn College, a community
school out in Texas, tweeting, Unfortunately, the
end of my high school career was robbed from me.
I didn't have the time other students
get to properly prepare for the future.
I look forward to attending Blinn College District
this year, a feeder school for Texas A&M. I'm
excited to join Texas A&M in 2023, so apparently
he's going to blend college, although how can we
know for sure? Because he wasn't exactly accurate
when it came to the Texas A&M situation. So
maybe in a week or two we'll find out that he
actually wasn't admitted there. And wouldn't
that be something? And you have to wonder also
if this is going to cause a wave of students to
leave Blinn College to transfer somewhere else
because they just don't want to associate with
Kyle Rittenhouse. And I feel mixed feelings about
that sort of thing, because on the one hand, those
students have every right to transfer if they just
don't want to associate themselves with Kyle. On
the other hand, Rittenhouse was put through the
criminal justice system, and he was found not
guilty by a jury of his peers. And so there's this
idea that he should be allowed to rejoin society,
and that can include seeking higher levels of
education and trying to better himself and all
these different things. So I do think he should
be able to go to college somewhere. But when when
you're talking about some specific college that
has to let him in or doesn't have to let him in,
that's where it gets tricky because the colleges
have every right to make their own decisions.
The students who go to those schools, they have
every right to make those decisions. So that's the
latest on Kyle Rittenhouse apparently becoming a
college student in the fall. I have for you today
one of the. Funniest moments from conservative
media in a while. It comes to us from Oann,
and they were doing this fluff piece about Donald
Trump. They were calling him a great president,
great patriot, and they had the sentimental
music going on in the background.
It's not even clear exactly why he was relevant.
To be doing right now is a story. But they were
doing it. They were showing that they have Trump's
back for the 2024 election if and when he decides
to run. And right after this sentimental piece
they did, they cut to a commercial break. And
what commercial was it but Viagra to make a really
awkward transition that will go down in television
history. Let's take a look at the clip we hear.
Speaker 2: One America News would like to say
thank you. President Trump, your legacy as a
patriot is unquestionable. You have inspired
countless millions and shown our nation what
it truly means to make America great again.
For one American news, I'm Pearson Sharp.
Speaker 5: Generic Viagra delivered
within 48 hours in discreet packaging on
approval. No one will know. But you look
and your mailbox Brexit Indeed.com is the fast,
easy and affordable way to get generic viagra.
Speaker 1: Now that is just the best, isn't it?
That is comedic gold right there, going from
that sentimental news segment right to a Viagra
commercial. And you have to wonder, like, did they
not realize that they were going to be throwing to
a Viagra commercial right away? So the transition
will be a little bit awkward. Did they not realize
that the segment was going to be so heartfelt and
sentimental? Like what exactly went wrong there?
And I feel like with O.J. and you kind of have to
wonder, are they all just trolling us over there
to the right wing commentators on that network?
Are they are they serious or are they just playing
a character? What exactly is going on? Because it
just seems so out there most of the time that you
have to think like they can't actually believe
this stuff. Do they really believe this stuff?
Maybe they are just trolling all of us. And in
terms of transitions being awkward on television,
that probably comes in first place. The one thing
that would maybe rival it, though, is back at the
beginning of the year when Russia had just invaded
Ukraine, there was a lot of coverage of the
war there on CNN. They were showing the sirens
going off at one of the Ukrainian cities,
followed up by a Applebee's commercial. That
really wasn't the best transition either.
Let's take a look at that one.
Speaker 5:
And little bit of chicken
fried. So we're all trying. Apaches are big.
Speaker 1: Just so you'll all have to tell
me which one you found more awkward. The land
transition or the CNN transition. And to me,
it's easier to laugh at the old one because the
CNN clip had some element of tragedy to it, right.
With the war going on. Whereas the only one you
could just take a look at that and be like, what
exactly is going on at that network? So that's
the latest on and we don't talk about them too
much anymore, but we absolutely had to cover this
story. Sarah Palin, former Alaska governor and 28
vice presidential nominee for the Republicans,
she is running for Congress, as we know. She's
trying to make a comeback into public life after a
long hiatus. And she is now past the first hurdle
for getting the job. This is actually a special
election that's going on in Alaska since Don Young
died earlier this year after representing the
at large district in Alaska for 49 years. Now,
Alaska has this interesting system where they
have all of their candidates, regardless of party,
appear on the same ballot for a first round of
voting. The top four vote getters then move on
to the next round of voting, where ranked choice
voting is used to determine who comes out on top.
We just had the first round of voting and we're
still getting the votes in. But as of now,
the results show that Palin has 29.8% of the
vote, followed by another Republican named
Nick Begich at 19.3%. Then we have Al GROSS at
12.5% and Democrat Mary Pallotta at 7.5%. So
those should be the four who advance and move on
to the second round. Notably, not making the cut
yet still getting an impressive 4.5% of the vote
was Democratic Socialist candidate Santa Claus,
which I didn't realize that Santa lived up in
Alaska. I thought he lived up in Canada or like
maybe the international territory that makes up
the North Pole. But apparently he's in Alaska.
RESIDENT And who knows, maybe he'll get them next
time. Palin's near 30% in the vote is a commanding
lead ahead of everyone else. But then when
you note that there's something like 50 other
candidates, you have to think about how the other
voters are going to coalesce when the candidate
number drops down to four. Also, you have ranked
choice voting, so that makes it a little bit
harder to predict compared to a normal election.
So who knows what will happen in the second round.
You just don't know who people are going to
coalesce around. Maybe the other Republican
will do better in the second round. Maybe the
independent Al GROSS will win. There's a good
chance that maybe she's not able to pull
this thing off. And that would, of course,
be a major blow to Trump's endorsement record and
to the state of Trumpism in this country. Because
not only is Palin endorsed by Trump, she and a
lot of ways with Trump before Trump was Trump,
notably based on how incompetent and inarticulate
she was. And we didn't realize that someone so
unqualified could serve in public office at such
a high level. But, you know, then we got Donald
Trump and now it's somewhat normalized. Also,
not helping Palin and Trump is the fact that
Alaska politics are a lot different than the rest
of the country. They tend to be more centrist and
they like the more reasonable candidates more
often than not. So who knows if she can pull it
off there? It's really just not the reddest state
in the country. Plus, many Alaskans view Palin as
a quitter because she quit her job as governor
ten plus years back to do a reality TV show.
So that just didn't sit very well with them. How
do they know that she's not going to resign early
from her seat in Congress? But fear not because
Palin has an excellent excuse in her back pocket
in case she doesn't come out on top. She went on
Mark Levin show a few weeks ago and she said that,
you know, if I don't win, clearly it's because of
voter fraud. Yeah, she's using that routine. Let's
take a look at this clip from about a month ago.
Speaker 3: Yeah. Whether I have a good shot or
not. There, there I think about 50
candidates in this race. It's a real
bizarre race. And as you say, 50 ballot 50. And
Mark, you'll just really appreciate this. It's
mail in only ballots, no hand counting to
tabulate. Got to go through a Dominion computer
to count everything. And by like yesterday, Mark,
I received four ballots in the mail. I didn't even
ask for any ballots. One for one of the daughters
who doesn't live here. She hasn't haven't cleaned
residents in Alaska since she moved outside.
We call anything outside of Alaska now.
Speaker 2: Trying to say Murkowski.
Speaker 3: Well, you know who wrote this bizarre
election plan that we have right now going on
with the ranked choice voting. That's coming
up. And the mail in ballots and all that
was Lisa murkowski's attorney, I believe
it was. Do I have a shot at it? Yeah, I have
a shot at it. It's it's bizarre, though,
you know, this kind of voting system. So I hope
the rest of America keeps track of what's going
on in Alaska so it doesn't happen to them.
Speaker 1: Well, that's certainly the Trumpian
playbook right there. If you win, everything was
on the up and up and you just got more votes from
the good people of your district or your state.
But if you lose, you didn't really lose. It was
just rigged. And what can you do? You were a
victim, so that's nice. You have that in your
back pocket as an excuse and you can really use
it in any election that you want to. Of course
I want Palin to be defeated and there's really a
good chance of that happening. We'll have to see.
It's going to be tight. But maybe this is a race
that we can get ourselves involved in. But part
of me wonders, like, if Sarah Palin does become
a congressperson, would that have entertainment
value? Would she have these wacky off the rails
speeches on the House floor that would be worth
watching. I also wonder if she would interact well
with people like Marjorie Taylor GREENE and Lauren
Boebert would she be too crazy for them? Would
they be too crazy for her? I just don't know. So,
you know, if she does end up pulling off the win
in this race, that will be like the one saving
grace. We get to see how she functions as a member
of Congress, but hopefully it doesn't get to that.
And hopefully Sarah Palin is defeated when
it's time for the second round of voting.
Of course, there'll be more elections to
come and we'll be following all of them.
All right. Thanks very much to David
for allowing me to host today's show.
And if you want to check out the bonus show, make
sure to become a member at join Packman dot com or
go to Patriot Tor.com slash David Pakman show and
contribute at the $5 level. I'll see you there.